allow me to reintroduce myself my name
is
the most snowflakes yeah Eminem's
daughter Elena Scott has a public
service announcement she's officially a
married woman the 30 year old sharing
behind the scenes videos from her big
day tying the knot with longtime
boyfriend Matt Mohler allow me to
reintroduce myself my name is home
snowflakes Elena also posted this shot
of her wedding decor she calls it the
table of my dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't want him helping that much with
the wedding it's just he's you know how
I am I know you know what I like how I
like it so it's really just like the
last hands in the pot the easier type of
thing yeah Elena and Matt got engaged in
December 2021 just months later the two
responded supporting her dad when he
performed during the 2022 Super Bowl
halftime show
education
[Music]
Elena is actually Eminem's adopted
daughter her biological mother is Don
Scott the sister of Eminem's ex-wife Kim
Scott whom he shares daughter Haley Jade
with in 2004 the musician told Rolling
Stone quote I was always there for Haley
and my niece has been a part of my life
ever since she was born me and Kim
pretty much had her she lived with us
wherever we was at and I bought you this
coin it says number one dad and soon
Haley will be a bride herself when did
you know you were going to propose I
would say the first time that I thought
about doing it seriously was uh
early summer
um
what who's that last summer
oh it took you long yep the 27 year olds
engaged to boyfriend Evan McClintock who
popped the question back in February and
on Haley's podcast just a little shady
he revealed he asked slim for his
Blessing before proposing it was a
holiday yeah over the holidays I uh
I was just looking for I saw your dad go
downstairs I'm like all right this I
gotta do it right now or am I doing it
today I'm gonna have to like schedule
some other time and uh so I just
followed him downstairs and thankfully
he was just down there grabbing your
cake and
that's so funny see like I had no clue
at the time Elena shared her excitement
for her little sis she wrote in part
quote there's not many moments in life
that leave you feeling pure Bliss but
this has to be one of them being able to
plan my own wedding and now experience
this with you Takes the Cake I feel like
I'm gonna be like in the middle because
I'll know what I don't want for sure but
I won't know what I actually want when
the time comes I mean who knows but um
Evan yeah
thank you
[Music]